Six Simple Steps to Avoid Food Poisoning.
Hey!
Psst!
It's two days past my use by date,...
...and it's about time I was thrown in the bio waste.
Listen carefully.
I'll tell you how to avoid many bouts of food poisoning.
Remember these six steps.
1. Wash your hands thoroughly before preparing food...
...and in all different stages of food preparation.
Do  not prepare food if you or your children are ill.
2. Use clean equipment.
Do not use the same equipment for different foodstuffs...
...such as meat, bread and vegetables.
If you do, make sure to thoroughly wash it in between steps.
Also, remember to wash your hands.
It prevents microbes from spreading.
3. Wash all vegetables, fruits and berries.
They are a surprisingly common cause of food poisoning.
Boil frozen berries sourced from abroad.
4. Make sure that meat is thoroughly cooked.
Cook mincemeat, poultry and pork until it is well-done.
Cuts of beef and lamb can be left medium on the inside.
5. Serve food immediately.
Keep hot food hot and cold food cold or chilled.
Put any leftover food in a cold water bath or in a smaller container...
...and refrigerate it as soon as possible.
6. Store your ingredients and food at the correct temperatures...
...to prevent bacteria from reproducing.
Check the use by and best before dates on the packaging.
Oh no!
I've got salmonella bacteria.
Remember what I said and throw me in the bio waste.
Ciao!